the uh the first question talks about
comedy festivals and this is from joyce
lyles basically her asking like
submitting to festivals how do you know
when you're ready
which one should you submit to
and um honestly personal experience
i haven't really done that many
festivals i haven't really participated
in that many festivals
um
but i've just i can share my two cents
but what what's your take on that yoshi
i've submitted to a lot of festivals and
i'm about like
2 and 40.
so just know that like it's not
it's not like a guaranteed thing that
you're gonna get in
i i did them just to like
see what happens in in some festivals i
appreciate the festivals that provided
feedback those are always great because
they have a world series of comedy does
that
yeah they provide feedback to let you
know you know this is why
either you got in or why you did get in
that's always helpful i say if you got
the money
submit but i there is an art to what you
do submit
and i learned this from world series and
some of the folks there and i remember
even like
there was a
like a class that we took there
where all the
uh i think
five of the clubs that were there just
did like a session and one of the things
that they said is like if you're doing a
five minutes and you're submitting even
for like a show
this is super important just straight up
facing straight because the
the festivals want to see your
expressions so that's helpful that's one
tip
tip number two
if you're editing always start with you
do not start with a host start with you
as the first thing that a festival sees
um and then the third thing is also like
know that even bookers and comedy
festival goers that are that are sort of
doing the contest
they may not watch your entire like five
minutes or your entire seven minute
special
so you have to almost rearrange your set
to like where your stuff that hits
really hard goes up top
and you still have to have like a good
five minute set but hit them with your
best stuff
up top those are the tips i can give for
festivals but if you've got the means i
say go for it um
you're gonna get a lot of rejections
because everyone's sort of applying but
i would find the ones that like either
like are close to you that you can
travel
uh to just quickly um and try it out i
always say also if you've got like a
local festival like in your town like if
you're in atlanta apply to atlanta
festival you're already in town just go
ahead and do that um but yeah but you do
have to have a strong
five minute seven ten minute set
um depending on what the festival uh is
is asking for but most festivals ask for
a strong five minutes so you would say
don't submit because that's joyce asks
like when do you know when you're ready
is it like when you have like a solid
five-minute set
when you have a solid five-minute set
yeah not to do like lpms or anything but
like it can't be below like four laps
per minute lpm's matter on like a five
minute set and like a submission set
yeah we're talking about gerard who's
doing like an hour but like a comedy
special but like yeah laughs per minute
definitely you want to pack them in
there especially when it's like a
submission set for sure yeah first so
for a submission set within five minutes
like
anything below four just isn't likely
going to cut it like you need like like
to get in there and three is
what you know that's what you teach
right you teach like first time comics
just try to go for three like if you're
getting four but like if you're in the
five to six range that's when you're
like hitting your stride for sure
yeah so get a tight five and then start
submitting to the to the festivals and
like and then they're great for
networking if anything you know you're
gonna meet a lot of other motivated
comedians
and they're the best thing about
festivals are the networking i would say
i mean i think that's the biggest value
add of it so it can be worth it if you
have the means
and um the time and the ability to
travel and such and that networking is
so big because i will say even till this
day and i've been in the game for seven
years
the majority of the bookings that i've
gotten have come from other comedians um
yeah for sure is it clubs it hasn't been
from
bookers it's been from other comedians
now bookers and clubs have booked me and
festivals have booked me
but where i get my work is from other
comics
yeah and i don't think um
she asked about the best festivals to
submit to i'm kind of out of the game i
mean i know
world series is good i think i've heard
limestone
big large
sky um
thousand i think it's a thousand miles
the one in
um
minneapolis
thousand lakes is also pretty solid even
uh what's the one that's in new york
the devil
something laughing devil
yeah something like that there's one
goldfest here in atlanta is good
play
um i would say before you submit ask
like even just post on our facebook
group and ask before you submit um
because
but like the limestones and like
even like the limestone
um and big sky
those festivals like
i would say do not submit to that as
your first festivals
here but like
that's like
big time
you gotta have like
not that you have to have representation
but
you gotta be like in the game game
before
you get that like
they're likely are not booking
first-year second-year comics
and we say that hey you may submit for
the first time in your new comic and you
may get in like
there's
what i just there's no one way to do
this it's just based on what we've seen
right
yeah yeah for sure you know the mold can
be broken like rosebud like got into jfl
four years in like we've seen people get
into jfo two years in like yeah it's
half people in this city gotten into jfl
two years into comedy so
there's you know the rules are meant to
be broken for sure
yeah and if you hear us like i'm going
to prove them wrong please go i mean
we're literally just trying to give you
our professional opinion but there is no
one way in this comedy game for sure
yeah for sure yeah if you prove us wrong
and you're like yo i made it into the
festival but i i'ma buy you a cake
you're saying like
if hey
for sure
[Laughter]
[Music]
cake
commercial
i rub rub rub
oh and denise said world comedy expo in
chicago the first one was this past
march yeah i saw people posting from
there she said it was excellent well run
nice yes there's good festivals out
there
i'm sure there there i mean there's bad
ones as well so like maybe if you're not
sure like post on our facebook group and
ask and i'm sure
you'll get a lot of good insights into
anything you ask in there for sure
um
but yeah
nice